jennifer lopez and ben affleck bust a
move at the super bowl just as their
rekindle love story heads for a
touchdown
you know it's wild to think about it
that way
check out the pair at sofi stadium for
the big game looking happy as ever and
yes even breaking into a little dance
party
and now et is learning new details about
benefit 2.0 in fact we're told their
romance feels like a fairy tale it just
turned out to be something really
magical the source tells e.t quote ben
and jen are open to the possibility of
getting engaged and married and their
loved ones would not be surprised if ben
pops the question the two words marry me
are those two words you would like to
hear in the future
[Music]
yeah i still believe in happily ever
after for sure and when it comes to
family ben and jen have got each other's
stamps of approval the source continues
quote they really trust each other and
that is so important to both ben's kids
really like jen and her kids love ben he
is incredible around them and makes them
all laugh they are they are so big and
so
amazing and happy and the family affair
doesn't stop at the little ones their
exes are also cool with it the source
adds jennifer garner is in a good place
with herself and with ben
so is j lo zex and father of their two
kids marc anthony he is always
supportive of her they are just really
great friends and co-parents he wants
her to be happy and happy is exactly how
the triple threat is feeling on saturday
jen gushed that she seriously melted
after getting an early valentine's day
gift from you know who ben affleck how's
that amazing last week the singer
revealed in her newsletter on the jlo
that ben directed a remix music video
for her single on my way
i was just passing through
i was on my way to you
she wrote watching it made me think
about the journey of true love it's
unexpected twists and turns and that
when it's real it actually can last
forever why not
yes
i'll marry you
you
the song is from her latest romantic
comedy marry me
this is smart
i think we left smart six weeks ago
that's ben walking the red carpet with
his valentine at the film's premiere
last week
it was a good good little meta
experience for me lopez stayed
tight-lipped about saying i do again but
she was all smiles when asked about her
date has been seen the movie yet you
brought your fella with you tonight he's
seen it yeah yeah this is just a good
date now it's a great date night we're
super happy
um
what can i tell you we're just having a
good time i would be remiss if i didn't
say you were standing taking photos in
front of a sign that says marry me
it's very big i didn't really realize
how big
[Music]
you